[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 85 of
the weekly google apart from podcast I
am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm very very very well how
are you doing I am very very very well
too and yeah in San Francisco for the
last day before gopher come very very
very very excited about that yeah it'll
be good yeah and also very excited about
really cool project I love open source
and we've been talking about like
kubernetes when we talk about prometheus
when we talk about so many projects that
are related somehow to the cloud native
computing foundation and this one is not
yet there but maybe soon yeah I think it
will be we're gonna have the luck to
talk to Vaughn Tiwari which is the
project manager of East EO and then
muslin which is one of the sovereign 10
years working there yeah super excited
to have them on the podcast talk about
how sto one of the first kubernetes
native projects I love that it's not
even cloud native is kubernetes yeah
projects to help with micro services and
help you manage and administrate them
and basically do all the stuff that
everyone kind of needs to do and at the
end we will actually have a question of
the week related to SEO which is ok so I
want to use East EO or my kubernetes
cluster I already have an application
it's the best way to get started and
there's actually a very good solution
that was created so we'll just talk
about that but before that we have a
bunch of cool things of the week so why
don't we go with them first yeah so the
first one coming up is a gentleman by
the name of I assume gentleman a person
of looked who his name is Vadim solavei
I think I got that vaguely right
according to his picture he has a beard
so I'm yeah it's a guy yeah the black
thing yeah so he wrote a blog post
stepping through a thing called G slack
integrating Google cloud platform with
slack which was basically set up so that
there was a bot that will tell you when
things happen inside your Google cloud
platform project so if you want nice
visibility across your project inside
slack he shows how that you can set up
essentially stackdriver logging
pub/sub then going to some cloud
functions to filter which notifications
you want to receive and then finally
pushing that into a slack channel nice
it's a really nice little article and I
think if yeah if I had a team that was
doing a bunch of stuff on a Google cloud
platform project I think this would be a
really nice way of giving them just
visibility of what's happening lots of
people use slack I've seen many
integrations where you do things through
slack so you deploy kubernetes cluster
with slack or whatever yeah but I like
this one because it's actually the other
way around is basically Google cloud
platform letting you know that
something's weird with your slack
project or whatever or that everything
is fine everything is fine or just
somebody did a thing hey somebody
deployed to nominate ease or somebody
push data to datastore or whatever it is
you want to know about I like it very
very cool next we have also a blog post
explaining how to treat this solution on
the Google opera from blog not podcast
and it explains how they build connected
vehicle apps with cloud IOT core I did
not know what cloud IOT core was and
actually we just sent an invite to
someone here the name of Gabe hey Gabe
hey Gabe we want to have you for the
podcast to talk about cloud IOT core but
basically what Toyota core does it
allows you to not only do data ingestion
from IOT devices but also manage the
devices themselves so all the part the
authentication authorization but even
like updating the software running on
those devices themselves is managed by
these by this framework so it's really
cool and they explain how using this and
MQTT which is a kind of message here
that we used to send them stuff to cloud
pops up and cloud dataflow you're
basically getting like how to manage
those vehicles and then how to ingest
all of the data is coming from it it is
very cool it is very intense like this
basically every single you have App
Engine compute engine container engine
cloud storage BigTable cloud dataflow
bigquery tensorflow
cloud dataflow again and pops up bingo
yay
oh and IOT core of course yeah so very
interesting use case covering a lot of
ground so go to get out if you're into
IOT or if you just curious about how we
can do cool things with lots of data and
then we have a cool thing of the week
which is you know not necessary
technology related but I'm gonna let you
go with it yeah so there is a wonderful
gentleman here in this SFO office by the
name of Bill prin Bill how you doin he
regularly posts writes these jerks on
the wall in the office um as you walk in
and today was fantastic
it was why did the gopher spend so much
time at the drugstore because he didn't
believe in generics really good outside
this morning when I got to the office
and I was okay okay
I'll take it I'll take it very good I
think maybe if bill keeps on cracking at
these good jokes maybe we should start
using them as part of the section the
week yeah I like it I like it
finally though we have a very short
video if anyone is familiar with Mario
and I'm sure many of you are was a
mobile application that came out a
little while ago called Super Mario run
it was quite popular it was actually
running on Google cloud platform and
there was a short video that was made
about how that was put together and the
team that made it at Nintendo and DNA
products they use it GCP it's a very
short it's like two minutes worth of
video but it's subtitled so if you don't
know Japanese it's totally fine yeah but
it's a super cute video where you could
see Mario run around and not only that
but you also get to see the engineers
actually using Google cloud platform and
you can see they're managing all the
monitoring with slack driver they're
using the query to run queries to see
how the Danny leagues are doing extract
deeper information is really cool and
then there's Mario jumping around so you
know you cannot go wrong with Mario
exactly awesome well why don't we go
have a chat with Varun and spin and talk
to them about this year sounds good
let's do that so I am very happy to
welcome today two members of the East
your team working from Mont of you
joining from Sunnyvale I think we have
Verne's of our
hello Vernon how are you doing hey I'm
doing well and we also have this van
Muslim how are you doing man doing great
good to be here
awesome thank you for coming so before
we get started talking about what Easter
is and I will be asking the question
what does it actually mean like that
word just you know
looks like we love Greek ports now in
the cloud why don't we talk a little bit
about who you are and what you do let's
let's start with Verone we had you for
episode 15 of the podcast talking about
your PC what are you up to now it felt
so good to be back
besides gr PC I'm now working on this
new project called sto and very excited
to be talking to you guys about it and
hopefully our listeners that are as
excited as we are building it and you're
acting as a product manager in the team
yes I'm a product manager on Google
cloud and love working on open source
awesome what about you Sven yeah I'm so
I'm one of the founders of the sto
project of a software engineer I've been
working in the API management and
service management space at Google for a
while and managing the team delivering
is to you well all right so why don't we
get started with like the basic question
so from a high level what is sto Varun
you're the PM why don't we can see get
it good explanation of the year all
right let's do it yes tio is an open
platform to connect manage and secure
services that's what you would read even
if you go to our website is teairra liar
essentially it's an open service mesh
where we would like developers and
operators to not have headaches about
how to connect services how to think
about making them resilient how to
secure them in how to manage the runtime
we would like each tio to be able to do
that for developers and operators across
all environments and clouds and when I
say services it's it's it's really all
kinds of services not necessarily just
micro we don't it could be anything
you're building you know my sequel API
surface a really small micro
is within your app so for payments or
shopping in any given language so sto
takes an approach of working with
polyglot environments you know no matter
what language you write your services
and then no matter where you deploy this
deal would like to give you a uniform
substrate between your application and
network which can take care of connect
connectivity between services resiliency
between services so resiliency includes
things like you know retries failover
all of the good stuff in distributed
systems securing services we think
internal services should be as secure as
external ones so security by default and
have complete observability and
visibility of metrics all the way from
you know l3 12:7 across all your
services cool so that sounds like a
great description from the point of view
of product manager you mentioned at the
first description that you gave of the
whole project set was something about a
service mesh what does it mean to be a
service mesh what is what is a mesh so
it's it's a fairly new term so it's
worth explaining what what that is
essentially you know think about a layer
and some people call it the l5 layer
which is basically a layer between your
application and your network and when
you think about it you are basically
creating we are injecting a proxy next
to every service and those are in the
data path of all the service to service
communication and the they are all
interconnected and also connected to a
common control plane and that
interconnected set of proxies which are
living next to every service was what
typically is being called as the service
mesh the reason it's so interesting is
that once you think of meshes as a layer
which exists like a network does you can
at the application layer start to
offload things like connectivity
resiliency security visibility to that
layer
so historically you would do this in
either application libraries so you know
if you're building in Java or Python or
go there's a there's a bunch of
libraries in each of these language
environments that you would import and
build logic into those and/or you would
do l3 level security and policy like IP
whitelisting firewalling VPN a you know
vp c is pairing and so on
so we think this is service meshes is a
space between the two which can offload
a few things from l7 and give policy
driven controls todra to operate your
network so the service mesh is kind of
the bit that sits between everything
it's kind of like the dark matter of the
universe service mesh isn't all the
different services that talk to each
other but instead the piece this is
between them and make sure that
everything goes okay between all of them
would that be a better right yes it's
the piece that makes sure that if you
think all your services as sort of nodes
in a graph mesh is basically making sure
you don't have to think about managing
the edges and everything that you have
to do on the edges which is how do I
connect them how do I retry my
connections there how do I load balanced
my connections there how do I apply
policy on my connections so that's
that's one way to understand what
Commission's cool so we were talking a
little bit about level 7 level 3 level 5
just a little bit for context I guess
it's worth mentioning that I'm assuming
you're referring to the OSI levels of
networking where a level 3 is networking
level 7 is application that is correct
what does it mean level 5 for you what
does it actually mean for you according
to this it means session which is you
know kind of an ambiguous term yeah
classic OSI stack is what I'm referring
to you know three is TCP or four is HTTP
GRP see also in the in a similar bucket
so yeah I'm saying I guess things above
HTTP layer again l5 is a sort of a just
a description to say it's above the
network and below the application I I
don't think it's a formal concept in the
in the other side
so then from the point of view of a
developer you basically like until so
far let's say that you have two services
and that they're running I don't know
like on Google cloud platform or compute
engine or something you have two
services and you want to do an HTTP
request one of those services is
exposing a REST API so what you normally
do is you just send an HTTP request so
HTTP will be the transport network would
be TCP whatever goes below we don't care
right how does easier changes this but
what is the change in the whole thing
that allows us to have all the security
and monitoring and all that good stuff
you were talking about essentially
service a talking-to service be in a
kubernetes environment which is what we
have privatized Sto
today but we would be hope to take it to
other environment soon you would
basically install a steal and we would
transparently intercept the A to B
traffic we would deploy what we call
sidecar proxies or basically proxies
next to a and B just keep it simple and
all a to b communication then becomes
you know the local proxy a to local
proxy b communication and once you do
that and once you know sto has
intercepted the traffic the proxies are
smart to do resiliency things like
retries circuit breaking fail overs and
once you once we are sto is intercepting
the traffic you can apply policies like
hey don't make more than you know 100
calls per minute from A to B on a rate
limit or a coda you could also do load
balancing between a and B without the
applications having to do anything you
could get all the telemetry between a
and B in terms of latency error rate QPS
between a and B without the applications
having to import and wire in monitoring
libraries which you would typically do
send you want to expand on that sure
yeah so the way I kind of think about
this is that this do is sort of making
your network a lot smarter so like from
an application view you don't have to
know about all the stuff that's going on
it's just suddenly your network now is
more resilient because you know you get
all that is like retries and circuit
and the things fern was talking about
and you get all these policies and no
you don't have to actually go and write
any code to do any of that
right it's just sort of automatic and
under the hood yeah we're adding these
psycho proxies and we're intercepting
traffic but that sort of implementation
detail that could change in future
versions of this the idea is really just
we want to make the network you know
operate at the service level off the
application level be able to do a lot of
these things that people are having to
write you know custom code in their
application to do today the network
should basically you know that for them
cool three new I mean you touched us a
little bit you said there was a priority
for kubernetes I've I've heard this
referred to as kubernetes native which I
kind of think he's quite cute why and
soon you might you might answer this
best why was that decision made to
prioritize communities and make that the
base platform for a CEO so there's
certainly a couple different parts to
that one is that we were sitting very
close to the kubernetes folks so that
you know made it easy to talk to them
about problems we were having more
seriously kubernetes provides a lot of
value and provides a lot of services
that we didn't have to go in Belen so it
provides a service registration
mechanisms or and you know orchestration
and all these other pieces it even
actually has some built-in
authentication that we're taking
advantage of so it really helped us get
to market a lot quicker with this
project because it had all those pieces
we didn't have to rebuild ourselves so
that was a big part of why kunos was
heard of that first target awesome okay
so let's let's talk practically then so
say I'm a developer this sounds really
cool I don't want to write all this
retrial logic myself or do a little as
security stuff myself I want to install
this do and have a play with it how do I
do that how do I make this thing work
with with my applications if you're
running on kubernetes you can just go to
sto dot io and go to the we have sort of
a tutorial section and one of those
tutorials is installing SEO it takes
about 5-10 minutes you can install in
your cluster and then there's a bunch of
actual sort of walkthroughs of different
things you can do with it after that so
you can play with the routing you can
play with the policy enforcement
authentication actually you don't really
have to do anything it just
automatically secures your communication
for you
but then if you want to write policies
against who is acting in your in your
mess you can do that so it's actually
pretty easy I'm sort of surprised every
time I go and do a demo of kind of how
easy it is to get started with this
thing it's really really just ten
minutes to get something useful up and
running and then if I want to configure
this year like you're talking about
being able to set up connectivity or
load balancing how do I go about doing
that right so this tool comes with a
command line tool called you steel
control that users familiar with
kubernetes cute control it's very
similar to that sort of model on it
basically you do the same thing you
would with kubernetes you write a file
and then you run these two control and
pass it the name of the file and it goes
and configures this to you and sort of
that's how you'll do things like set up
a quota so you could write a file that
says you know user a calling service B
only gets on your QBs that's you know
maybe one or two lines of configuration
you write these to control and now
that'll actually be enforced cool and
with these you really get things like
quota as we're talking things like we
trying in case the service is down what
about the monitoring is it a dashboard
there that's integrate with all the
services like I don't know like a stack
driver or how does this work right so so
what a miss do is sort of philosophies
is that we don't want to build things
other people have built so we didn't
build a heavy monitoring ourselves right
we're using other monitoring systems the
first one we support is Prometheus and
we sort of know out of the box
Prometheus support out of the box a
Prometheus dashboard actually that will
automatically show you all your services
and their traffic and theirs and a bunch
other useful things and there's sort of
metrics that we collect by default and
then you can go and extend that as a
user and have more metrics at better
dashboards and Alerts whatever you want
just one night to add what this do gives
you is more traffic signals more l.7
metrics into the systems that you're
already using for monitoring so back to
our example a talking-to be yes you're
interested in you know how much CPU
utilization and you know network
bandwidth and resources being used by NB
but you're probably more interested in
what is the latency from A to B what is
the error rate between a and B
how many response cords by percentage
and so the things at l7 that you're
interested in used to sort of just get
out of the box yeah I'm actually very
specifically thinking of that example
where I would probably have had sort of
some sort of try-catch error code on
both sides of my application that would
have caught that error like either
sending or receiving and then sent that
up to some sort of monitoring unit but
now with this do I can put this in
between and it's gonna handle all that
sort of things for me that sounds really
cool yeah I just wanted to mention that
for our listeners for more complex and
Prometheus we actually released an
episode with one of the founders of the
project Julie's falls on with episode 82
so if you want to know more about it go
check it out so I was gonna ask another
question since we also have Rouen here I
know there's Nicole at magic there's
some special bits and pieces in there
that are particular for GR PC as well
that sort of work out of the box can you
talk about some of those yeah so you
know the approach here is it should work
even if you our services our geo PC
services right so each tier should work
the same way hopefully better because
you're getting you know the http/2
advantages and so on so the interesting
thing here is you know the the proxy in
sto understands your PC so basically you
don't have to do any transcoding from
like rest to your PC or you know you
don't have to do that heavy lifting
because the proxy understands them so
our goal here is sto as such works with
G RPC services as well of course in
future we we can make it even better
that you can have the policies you apply
and you know security principles you
apply they can work with 2g RPC services
even without proxy so we are not there
yet but I think our goal is to enable
people to have all these capabilities if
you use you know proxy in the middle or
you know all if you just build with G
RPC you still get a lot of the
connectivity resiliency and similar kind
of traffic management and policies that
these two supports and we're an ACL also
do G RPC the rest can
so it will eventually it doesn't quite
yet that's sighted I was reading it and
I saw that it's like oh that's so cool
yeah that's very interesting actually
since we're talking about the road map
yeah we're trying to mimic the next
releases yeah that's actually a feature
that there's you know someone in the
community actually created a GRC gateway
that does that based on the sort of
standard annotations that Google
released and we've also released a cloud
endpoints product and also does this and
yeah we're very committed to letting
people write G RPC services and have
those serve people using your PC but
also people just using H to be cool so
since we're talking about the road map
I wonder what before we talk about the
road map is East East yeah version 1.0
already is this something that I should
be running on production
not yet and if not when the version so
far is actually 0.1 it's ok yes it's
like 1.0 just the other way it's frankly
the smallest number we can come up with
No so we don't actually recommend people
use this on production the proxy itself
the Envoy proxy is production-ready it's
been in production impairments for you
know at least a year if not longer left
but the other pieces are new and so
people aren't worried about it at all
the question Ronit yet we're sort of
furiously working on you know more
stability more performance more
reliability of those components to make
sure that you know the bar of quality is
much higher on the next release and
that's where we expect people should
sort of have no problems with using this
in production that's it I think there's
already people using this in production
and being fine with it so you know by
are we aware but there are people doing
that cool so please do not use these in
production but even though some already
do that's but if you are feedback so
that the product can get better so then
the question the question is what is the
roadmap when do you think is like what
are the next features that you're
working on
what why should we expect in the coming
months or maybe next year yeah so we're
actually we're trying to release pretty
pretty often so we're actually hoping to
get at least two more releases in this
year the next release so there's a lot
of stability and performance and sort of
figuring things out going into that so
we learned a lot in the first release a
lot of it was sort of you know about
taped together to try and just make all
the pieces work and maybe not
necessarily the sort of write that
long-term design we're trying to
finalize for example how partners and
vendors and other interested parties can
add their own backends and their own
features to sto and do that very simply
today it's a little bit harder than we'd
like so we're sort of doing a lot of
refactoring to clean that up probably
the biggest item in the next release is
actually going to be support for raw VMs
so outside kubernetes being able to run
this on just their VMs which kind of
means you can run it basically anywhere
although it'd be more effort than
codenys Corday's this one line Bob VMs
will take more because you have to run
all the different parts yourself right
so that's that's probably the biggest
piece and then after that hopefully in
the sort of third release what I really
want to see is what we call hybrid which
is you know maybe I'm running a couple
different clusters and some VMs and they
want all those to be sort of part of one
mesh and be able to communicate with
each other and have consistent
authentication and security and all the
goodness and history of rings that is
actually a very difficult task though or
hopefully up for it so hopefully another
release that will be coming out very
nice so actually that's interesting so
then you mentioned said crust clusters
so does SEO work outside in or does it
work as well like is it can I if I have
to kubernetes clusters and I want to
send information between them I'm
guessing the monitoring is separate and
the aggregation is separate but even if
I have just external people using my
api's that'll still come in through SEO
otherwise it's not just internal -
cleburn eddies right so yeah that's a
good that's a great question so it's -
it does come with what's called an
ingress controller so if you're just
using kubernetes communities has an
ingress resource that lets you configure
sort of how things coming into the
cluster act really in the HTTP level
only and issue has an implementation of
that so that the Envoy proxy basically
acts as an inner ingress proxy and
secures everything once it hits that
point so when things are
into the sto world into this Umesh
everything gets cured so yeah we have we
have that apartment we don't have yet is
sort of those two clusters sort of
knowing about each other and being able
to do things like global load balancing
across things and failover and another
set of the really cool stuff you can do
once you know about everything in both
places right that that's what's really
interesting before we finish we're kind
of running out of time but there's one
question that I said I would ask and I
didn't ask yet which is what does each
tier mean as you know we love Greek
words here at Google cloud and they seem
to do well in open source so it
technically I think it's sale in Greek
helps man kubernetes we sort of going
with the analogy we had not just
kubernetes first we'll also take
inspiration from their naming so with
that name there was another hope that we
would get east at i/o but I figured that
wasn't available and and we shouldn't
gonna have stickers so you know becomes
a real project when you have stickers
when your stickers and t-shirts so that
the webpage for those that would like to
learn more about the project is easier
that I know yes Jared IO is the website
and you know we've tried
I think it's decent documentation and
getting started and I'm just looking at
it and it's it's adorable I was just
gonna real quick say that honesty I know
there's also a lot more of this sort of
philosophy behind this to you as well as
just getting started so you can learn
more about you know why we created it
and how it works and sort of what the
driving philosophies are behind it which
is all at least I think is pretty
interesting
great well thank you so much for taking
the time today to tell us a little bit
about it still and get us excited about
the roadmap awesome thanks for having us
yeah it's great beer so thanks again to
Varun and van to spend the time to tell
it'll be more about East EO about the
goals and roadmap and a little bit of
the history of it sure so very very
interesting open source project and the
question of the week for today is
actually related to the same topic it's
about each do and of course kubernetes
and the question is basically I use
coronaries I love it and I'm already
using
with some applications my application
have I have all the camels to describe
the services and the pods and all that
stuff and I want to use eesti oh how do
I do this like what is the best way is
there like maybe some tutorial to
explain how to do this or yeah so this
is a really good question so ever
actually there is actually a really
great blog post on the kubernetes blog
will link to in the show notes
managing micro services with the sto
service mesh where what it does is it
takes an existing book info application
and then goes and applies easier to it
so that you can see metrics around
ingress traffic in and out and see how
that works the thing that it highlights
and I think that's kind of neat is
easier comes with sto CTL or is your
control depending on how you like to
pronounce it cuddle Easter know it coz
CL and one of the commands it has is a
thing called cube inject basically the
documentation reads that the invoice ID
card that is tio uses isn't
automatically injected with sto at least
not yet
it's a project in progress so they may
give there eventually but instead you
can use this cube inject command on sto
CTL where you can hand it a group and
Eddie's llamo and then it will change
the configuration for you and basically
you can do that as many times as you
like and then as the project is to your
changes which probably will still in
progress
you can keep redoing that to apply that
inverse and voice ID car in a canonical
way Forestier going forward so it's
actually a really nice little toolkit
showing how you can do things it is
interesting I think that yeah the the
way they show how to do it is like QTL
apply of output of running east your CTL
cube inject mmm not a huge fan of that I
think that probably if you're generating
so an intermediate llamó you'd like to
store it like yeah chasing think case
yeah I think you should keep the
original and what you've generated
yeah so you can always reapply and see
what differences happen yeah but on that
super cool tool if you're getting
started with East you have a look at it
definitely the blog post super
interesting lots of detail just a little
like complain about it they show how you
can run like on the book info they get a
bunch of different languages so there's
models rename Python Java Ruby and node
yeah what's problem I don't
yeah yeah sure but yeah other than that
very good very interesting project they
even describe how once this has been
done you can start seeing all the graphs
and monitoring on graph Anna so very
very cool definitely check it out and
have a try that cube inject cube eject
soap come on
awesome so I believe when this comes out
you're gonna be at graphic on yes by the
time this comes out I will be getting
ready to teach my workshop gopher con on
performance analysis of CO programs
using heat proof and the go tracer nice
yeah lots of content in there it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be full day of
performance profiling so yeah sounds
good and speaking of workshops I know
you just released one - that's been
doing very well so I made a better video
a long time ago when I went to go to go
con Chicago and it was called go tooling
in action and I made a workshop from it
for to come I was in here two weeks ago
and I open source the thing and he got
like 1200 stars on github so damn
yeah I'm famous now yeah I made it I
don't think I'm gonna open sores
anything else ever again
good yeah I'm done here done yep I'm
done and also since we're talking about
things that I've really lady I just
released also latest episode just for
funk so I cover I have to log stuff and
manage errors and handling signals and
stuff like that to make programs are
really robust and it's a quick review
from a piece of code that Sandeep wrote
notes and ignition from our team what
about you what are you up to how's your
open-source life going good it's going
well so I will be a New York summit next
week cool which is cool I will be teeing
there's a cooping at east boot camp
that's happening the day before so if
you're interested in getting
kick-started from a basic level what
kubernetes doing I'll be there helping
that out there's also an ml and
tensorflow one that's also going on at
the same day is that still open for
people to subscribe well we have a show
link in the show notes yes yes
definitely they will be linked to the
show notes it is it is the day before
the summit and there's still plenty of
room for people to get involved awesome
which is good and most recently I
finally got to the second part of what
apparently it's going to be a five-part
blog first series nice
scaling and deploying dedicated game
servers with kubernetes so I've just put
out one that's all about how to manage
memory on kubernetes so this may not be
necessarily a specific to like game
servers you may find it kind of
interesting if you're just like how much
memory is my process using and should I
put limits on it and that kind of stuff
yeah I think it's regardless of your
interesting video games or specifically
paddle soccer I think it is very
interesting it shows basically how to
how to monitor how much memory how much
CPU you have in your cluster which is
cool
it's rather than having it per pod you
can also see like a little bit more of
your idea of what the whole cluster is
up to yeah but also like if you're like
I don't even know how much memory my
pods using like yeah which is useful
awesome
well franceska thank you once again for
joining me for a wonderful episode of
the Google cloud platform podcast thank
you Mark and thank you all for listening
alright and we'll see you all next week
[Music]